we pivot to the united states now he
became the face of the u.s capitol
rights on january 6. jacob chansley also
known as
kunan shaman pled guilty to obstructing
congress well today he will be sentenced
prosecutors have asked for four years
behind bars a lengthy jail term they say
would act as a deterrent to similar
attacks in the future
face paint a furry hat with horns
tattoos all over and a six-foot spear in
his hand
this man became the public face of the
capital riot on january 6th
originally from arizona chancelling who
is also a u.s navy veteran defined
himself as a former actor and kianan
leader
a far-right cult centered on false
claims
chancelley pleaded guilty in september
to obstruction of an official proceeding
by an act of civil disorder and
threatening congressional officials
he spent more than 300 days in jail
he is one of more than 50 people who
have pleaded guilty among 600 charged in
the riot that forced lawmakers into
hiding as they were meeting to certify
president joe biden's electoral college
victory
five people died and there were assaults
against 139 police officers
an attack on u.s democracy that shocked
the world
prosecutors recommended a prison
sentence of more than four years for
chansley the longest incarceration they
have asked for any guilty defendant of
january 6 so far
the prosecutors hope to use chancellor's
sentence as an example to deter future
attacks on u.s government
that report by my colleague carolina
chamoy and she joins us now from
washington carolina what's your reading
how do you think this will go
hi laila well we just heard it they the
prosecutors recommend more than four
years in prison for chansley and this
would be the longest incarceration they
have asked for any guilty defendant of
january 6. the prosecutors they argued
that chansley was among the first 30
people to enter the capital and that for
weeks before the riot he used his social
media accounts to spread false
information that also motivated other
writers to to head to the us capital he
was a kind of leader for many um on that
day and he even defined himself after
the riot as a kiana leader um he also
played guildy in september to
abstraction of an official proceeding
and this would usually mean a sentence
of maximum 20 years in prison but under
a plea agreement with the government mr
chansley faces now a potential sentence
of 41 to 51 months that means more than
four years carolina contextualized this
for us what is the significance of this
case
well we all saw him on on january 6th
intensely he was one of the most
recognizable participants in the riot
and let's remember he was walking down
the halls of the capital shirtless with
a painted face holding that six foot
spear and he was among the first 30
people i already said it um going into
the capital on january 6 and therefore
he became rapidly one of the most famous
faces of that riot therefore his
sentence will also set an example for
the other capital rioters and and their
cases in court and while detention this
is important to point out leila
chancelli was diagnosed by prison
officials with
schizophrenia with a bipolar disorder
with depression and anxiety and when
when he entered his um guilty plea he
said he was disappointed of uh former
president donald trump because he had
not pardoned him and it's been a very
busy week carolina this isn't the only
event related to the january six riots
indeed a very busy a week we all also
have a different case in kenosha that is
about a different uh well murder we we
saw in um in the summer but also
regarding this riot layla more than
675 people have been already arrested
for crimes related to that capital riot
and according to the justice department
more than 50 people have pleaded guilty
so we'll still remain on this story and
see um how the sentence goes on for
tensley and if this is indeed going to
set an example for the other cases all
right carolina dw correspondent in
washington reporting thank you very much
and all eyes in the united states are
also on another high profile case
anticipation is at fever pitch as the
country awaits a verdict from jurors
weighing charges against kyle
rittenhouse the teenager faces life in
prison if convicted of killing two men
and injuring a third he shot the three
men during protests against racial
injustice in kenosha wisconsin back in
august 2020. mr rittenhouse has
testified he acted in self-defense the
case has become a flashpoint in the u.s
debate over gun rights and racial
tensions
was it an act of self-defense or
gratuitous violence
that's a question facing 12 jurors as
the u.s awaits the verdict of kyle
rittenhouse
he was just 17 years old when he shot
dead two people and injured a third in
kenosha wisconsin last august
protests swept through the city after
police shot a black man jacob blake
leaving him partially paralyzed
it came just three months after the
murder of george floyd an incident that
stunned the world and left america
reeling
sparking a wave of anti-racism
demonstrations at the height of the
covid pandemic
rittenhouse who faces life in prison if
found guilty claims he was there to
protect property and provide first aid
he traveled there from neighboring
illinois with a semi-automatic rifle
reportedly given to him by a friend
awaiting a verdict protesters in support
of and against written house have
gathered outside kenosha county
courthouse for days
the judges pleaded with the jury to set
aside any political or public commentary
and focus on the facts
but in a case which crystallizes the
country's polarizing views on the issues
of race police violence and a growing
culture of vigilantism the outcome of
the trial will have implications far
beyond the fate and future of kyle
rittenhouse